[Musique]
ça m'aide en fait à être plus forte
en fait j'ai accepté c'était pour me
donner un peu plus confiance en moi
parce que je n'aimais pas me regarder
par rapport à ma perte de cheveux par
rapport à tout ce que le corps a subi et
donc je ne vais pas me regarder
dans un miroir et cette séance de photos
en fait c'était justement pour me
pour me redonner confiance en moi ça a
été une belle expérience
il y avait une belle complicité
et ça c'était fort
[Musique]
hu
à moitié elle est trop belle
montre elle est à la la c'est une belle
femme
[Musique]
ah
ah ben je suis trop belle
[Musique]
j'aime moi j'aime ce que je vois
j'aime ce que je vois et
elle a été courageuse parce qu'à
plusieurs reprises elle a eu envie de
baisser les bras
suite au bond la chimio parce que
c'était très très très dur
et pendant que je faisais c'est pendant
la maladie c'est vrai que je perdais ma
grande soeur aussi deux camps series
en fait j'avais pas encore fait mon
deuil
et
et je suis contente en fait que ce
qu'elle est devenue la la
parce que je suis devenu
et elle est magnifique ah oui et je veux
je veux rester cette femme là
[Musique]